ground if you were to say somebody who
you went up against went up against that
ground game it's just could be khabib
nurmagomedov
yeah would you put him like in a league
of his own a lot of people call him as
the league of his own type of guy would
you ever felt anything like it you know
and i have 46 fights i fought all kind
of different people all kind of
different styles
been around the world training in gyms
this guy
this guy's good what's what's unique
about it tell us about me
his understanding of his weight
distribution where my weight needs to be
to keep me up to build back up and and
his understanding of uh grappling is is
impressive is i mean the best i've ever
felt the best i've ever seen you know
the guy's 30-0
and mma that's a hard thing to do
there's so many variables there's so
many ways to lose
and to be 30-0
against the best guys in the world
is
you know very impressive but
his understanding of what i needed to do
and what positions i needed to be in
to advance
he was just he was steps ahead of me so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you